moi je veux que je dis aux entreprises
voilà si vous augmentez de 10%, les
salaires jusqu'à trois fois le SMIC et
bien je gèlerai les cotisations
patronales subséquentes il y a
l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales subséquentes on voit bien que
la mesure que je propose d'augmentation
des revenus et quelque chose qui est
capable d'améliorer la vie quotidienne
des Français parce que vous administrez
les salaires mais oui mais vous
n'administrez pas les primes non plus
monsieur
j'enlève j'incite et j'enlève les
charges et les impôts mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que j'assume pour
le coup cette mesure et je rempl
obligatoire le mécanisme mais vous
n'augmentez pas de 10% les salaires ce
qui veut dire Emmanuel Macron il disait
vous n'allez pas imposer au Patrice
d'augmenter une [ __ ] de 10% est-ce que
c'est possible ou pas mais non non bien
sûr que non c'était elle voulait inciter
avec le gel des cotisations patronales
mais on peut pas administrer on peut pas
d'augmenter les salaires de 10% de
passer devant le Parlement et bon c'est
pas non plus ça qu'elle a expliqué dans
son programme donc faut aussi un peu
c'est vraiment dans le programme une
incitation pourquoi parce qu'il y a
certains patrons qui hésitent à
augmenter leurs salariés ou à rendre
leur poste plus attractifs pourquoi
parce que s'ils augmentent de 10 % paf
c'est 20% en fait en plus parce qu'il y
a les charges et donc si demain Benjamin
Castaldi vous demande une augmentation
non non non
en tout cas jusqu'à hauteur de 3 fois le
SMIC c'est 10% oui c'est du salaire pour
le salarié mais il y a pas de charge
dessus donc le patron ne paye que le
salaire et l'État ne perd rien ne sert à
rien parce que il a et voilà ces charges
là elles ne sont pas là mais elle ne
sait pas encore je crois que c'est
beaucoup plus simple c'est Macron il a
démasqué cette supercherie vous venez de
confirmer français
supercherie c'est ce qu'elle a fait là
c'est peut-être pas réalisable bien
évidemment qu'elle peut pas changer le
bruit d'un salarié elle propose
Président vous êtes d'accord bon bah
parler tout seul non je parle avec je
tiens un dialogue vous avez l'habitude
de dialogue je laisse parler depuis tout
à l'heure me raconter
beaucoup de monde à la télé la télé
beaucoup de monde 15 millions vous avez
dit vous êtes contents parce que ça fait
15 exactement le même chiffre qu'avant
tF1 aurait fait 15 TF1 et France 2
réunis aurait fait la même chose vous
auriez mis un film et un autre film ça
aurait fait et vous prenez les scores de
BFM et toutes les chaînes en font Unies
ça n'a pas fait plus que que d'habitude
les gens sont pas assez vous avez dit
combien Emmanuel Macron est violent
quand il a quelqu'un d'extrême droite en
face de lui il a c'est pas vrai il a
arrogant même avec les Français qui
rencontre dans la rue et pourtant tous
les Français sont pas d'extrême droite
ils ont voté pour lui la parole pour qui
vous coupez la parole moi donc me coupez
pas la parole je vous dis que ça
ressemble un peu vous me dites je me
trompe et vous me dites si je me trompe
si vous les économies c'est pas moi ça
ressemble un peu comme des sortes
d'heures sup de Sarkozy déguisé est-ce
que c'est caresser Nicolas Sarkozy avec
les heures sup ex défiscalisé c'est un
peu ça ça ressemblait un peu à ça sur le
coup Emmanuel Macron lui dit vous avez
pas changé le brut il a raison on peut
pas changer il va pas décider il va pas
décider elle va pas décider combien ton
patron va te payer mais
avouez que l'idée l'idée elle est pas si
folle que ça l'idée de remettre le
travail au centre c'est bon là on va
passer
on va revenir sur ce qui a été dit au
travail on est d'accord Emmanuel Macron
et Marine Le Pen aussi n'était pas
d'accord sur un point très important
pour les Français le pouvoir d'achat
Emmanuel Macron assuré que le pouvoir
d'achat des Français avait augmenté sous
son cancana Marine Le Pen assuré que non
on va vous dire qui a raison c'est parti
Madame Le Pen a raison de dire que les
chiffres en effet qui sont pas les miens
qui sont ceux des organismes
indépendants de l'INSEE et autres
établissent très bien que sous ce
quinquennat le pouvoir d'achat en
particulier de tous les Français mais
des Françaises et des Français qui
travaillent et qui sont les classes
moyennes et populaires à augmenter mais
les chiffres en moyenne
ne viennent pas aider à finir le moi
quand la vie devient plus chère comme
depuis plusieurs mois monsieur Macron je
vous ai entendu avec votre gouvernement
vous réjouir d'avoir augmenté le pouvoir
d'achat des Français je n'ai vu que des
Français me dire qu'il n'y arrivait plus
qu'ils ne s'en sortait plus qu'il
n'arrivaient plus à boucler les fins de
mois alors vous avez fait des choix vous
avez fait le choix de mettre en place la
taxe carbone qui aggravait le prix de
l'essence et moi je veux véritablement
faire du pouvoir d'achat de la priorité
de mon prochain quinquennat chez les
Français me font confiance alors tu as
raison alors ça ça dépend des études en
fait ah c'est assez formel oui le
pouvoir d'achat a augmenté depuis 2017
0,9% il y en a qui explique que c'est
1,3 mais il y a une nuance qui est
importante c'est vrai c'est que ce sont
les plus aisés qui ont bénéficié de ce
cette augmentation du pouvoir de la 300
€ pour les 10 % les plus modestes c'est
07% pour les 10% les plus aisés c'est
2,2% donc c'est trois fois plus pour les
plus aisés et c'est là où cette nuance
elle est importante de d'être
il y a moi bien sûr que tout ça est vrai
mais il faut être clair et le président
de la République Emmanuel Macron est
très lucide il n'arrête pas de dire
qu'il va répondre à la question du
pouvoir d'achat par le travail par des
aides il a dit en particulier avec la
prime la prime emploi qu'il veut rester
assimile d'abord je rappelle que pendant
la crise il a nationalisé les salaires
il a sauvé la situation d'énormément de
français parce que c'était la crise donc
il a déjà démontré d'autre part il a
augmenté la prime d'activité il a
augmenté le minimum vieillesse et
apporter la retraite des agriculteurs à
1000 euros je peux il faut aller plus
loin parce que le pouvoir d'achat est un
vrai sujet il faut que les Français des
Vikings
moi je me méfierai d'un truc c'est que
cette idée de fact checker en permanence
des chiffres et de transformer ce duel
présidentiel qui a un rendez-vous
important pour les Français en grand
oral de l'ENA donc tout le monde n'a
rien à faire c'est ça boutique quand
même comme aux États-Unis à ce que les
électeurs se disent peu importe que le
chiffre soit vrai ou faux je vote pour
Trump et j'en ai rien à faire de ce que
les médias me disent ils se sont fait il
a été bêtises etc méfions-nous de
comment les Français vont interpréter ce
petit jeu de le chiffre est bon le
chiffre est pas bon si ça correspond pas
à une émotion qu'il ressente et à ce
qu'ils vivent moi je crois que c'est
l'espoir qu'on aurait dû leur donner et
à mon avis ils l'ont pas trouvé hier
mais c'est assez déceptif moi je pense
si j'ai un regret aussi hier je vous le
dis moi j'ai trouvé que les candidats
n'ont pas parlé avec leur cœur non les
deux ils sont pas parlés avec leur cœur
en français je suis désolé à un moment
on aurait aimé les voir parler aux
Français leur dire des choses avec des
mots simples avec son cœur
comme pilier débats je suis désolé mais
vous vous êtes toujours l'empêche de
tourner
quoi
Sarkozy je suis désolé
en 2016
en tout cas en tout cas Emmanuel Macron
j'ai trouvé le débat des humanisé je
suis désolé alors en tout cas en tout
cas Emmanuel Macron a parlé avec la
raison
la connaît la raison et vu le moment
je crois c'est le dealer je crois que
c'est le discours de la raison je crois
que le discours de la raison en ce
moment c'est très important c'est la
raison donnez-moi et ça c'est la France
et ça c'est la France il y en a marre il
y a la raison il y a les abrutis
il y a les racistes
plus personne
plateau vous êtes à TPMP et alors 30%
des téléspects
pour le rassemblement national où ont
voté pour Marine Le Pen est-ce que pour
autant vous croyez que vous avez 30% de
racistes qui vous regardent est-ce que
vous croyez en train de vous alors il
faut arrêter monsieur vous avez entendu
en revanche xénophobies je pense qu'il
est tout à fait vrai chez vous
c'est-à-dire la peur de l'étranger
par les gentil chez vous c'est Bruno
Gollnish il m'a insulté
de TPMP vous n'arrêtez pas d'insulter
les gens écoutez pour l'instant
excusez-moi qui a créé moi plaisir dans
son souvenir et d'extrême droite c'est
vous merci les chéris en fait nous c'est
30% Jean-Luc Mélenchon examen pour cent
Marine Le Pen 19% Emmanuel Macron pour
les grands voilà les les trois
principaux c'est 30 30 19 voilà hier
c'était trop les quoi j'ai dit hier
c'était trop lisse comme débat c'est
entre ici il y a plein de sujets qui ont
été invités les 600 milliards ça a été
évité ça a été balayé d'un revernon on a
l'impression que ni Marine Le Pen
voulait attaquer Emmanuel Macron elle
l'a laissé faire une
manuel Macron n'a attaqué on a attaqué
Marine Le Pen et même à la fin de
l'émission quand on demande arrêtez de
faire ça quand on demande aller à ça
la met à la fin elle voit les deux il se
lève et il partent et qu'est-ce qu'ils
se disent ils vont ils se font une
accolade et peut-être 5000 était là et
ils se disent ah bah c'est quand même
c'était quand même mieux qu'il y a 5 ans
il réjouit il se réjouissait tous les
deux de ce qui s'était passé sauf que
les Français se sont pas réjouis et
prenez le prenez-le les chiffres les
chiffres qui sont très bas parce que
vous êtes 15 millions c'est beaucoup
prenez-le comme le début de la première
absorption ça c'est la première action
quand les gens sont tous les gens
souffrent ils ont besoin qu'on leur
parle avec le cœur et c'est vrai ce que
dis Cyril c'est que Marine Le Pen et
Emmanuel Macron hier n'ont pas parlé
avec le cœur il regardait les
journalistes ils se regardaient entre
ils déroulaient leur truc ils mettaient
leur petite stratégie en place et les
gens les téléspects les spectateurs
n'ont pas ressenti venez de décision du
cœur aujourd'hui
Macron Seine-Saint-Denis et il avait
l'air d'avoir un retour avec des gens et
inversement enfin du débat d'hier
excusez-moi à ajouter
et on peut l'entendre et puis il y en a
pas commencé c'est c'est ce que on
ressenti les téléspectateurs qui
comptent je crois que l'exercice est
tellement formel que c'est compliqué
aussi d'en sortir je crois vraiment
sincèrement et je vous le dis parce que
je la connais que Marine Le Pen dans
tout ce qu'elle a dit était sincère mais
pour le coup et moi et moi Emmanuel
Macron que voilà que vous avez voilà un
peu aussi ne croyez pas quand il voyait
les gilets jaunes dans la rue il était
il aurait aimé qu'il disait je sais que
ça l'attristé il aurait pu le dire hier
oui j'étais attristé par telle chose
j'étais resté par telle chose pendant
mon vous avez bien vu son attitude il ne
reconnaît jamais on a envie de voir ça
aussi Eduardo parce que je suis d'accord
avec vous parce que il a un gros cœur
vous la connaissez comment on le voit
pas il a il a un très gros cœur c'est un
affectif il aime ce pays il aime les
gens de ce pays comme vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer il a appris moi je crois ça je
pense que ce sera le quinquennat si les
Français lui font confiance parce que
c'est pas jouer je le dis à tout le
monde c'est pas joyeux je jouais pas
avec le feu la vérité du feu c'est que
le feu ça brûle c'est aussi simple voilà
j'ai envie de dire un truc simple ça
sera le quinquennat peut-être du cœur
parce qu'il il faut la Concorde et
rassembler le pays je pense que le
Président on a envie il a ce désir alors
donne-lui la force de rassembler avec un
profil
de celui qui parle bien celui qui fait
prenait des décisions prenez tout le
temps de la mère merci beaucoup